hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that just ended from the
women's European Team Championship 2023
it is Greece versus Ukraine and on board
one we have stava soloko versus Natalia
bua and uh I've already made a video
named the greatest Queen sacrifice of
2023 but I made it already in January
because I thought okay there's no way
that anyone tops that but this could
very well be the queen sacrifice that
topped that Queen sacrifice if you
haven't seen that video it's the one of
course between Max feram and yush pach
first link in the description below so
if you haven't seen it check out that
Queen sacrifice before you watch this
one and then you guys will be the judge
of that and then only one video uh will
remain with this title until the end of
time so it's a pretty big responsibility
if you decide to do that now let's check
it out we've already seen a game by
stula uh a month ago on this channel
from the Women's Club cup she played
against Elena danielia and with that
tricky night and it was uh really wild
wild attacking game so uh let's see what
she has in store for us uh this game
really wild stuff here so uh we have
Pawn to E4 by stula and pawn to C5 by
Natalia going for the Sicilian Defense
we have Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and D4
okay pretty standard stuff captures
captures Knight to F6 Knight to C3 and
E5 and uh yeah one thing that I think
you guys might find interesting is that
their game is following a game mag Magus
Carlson played against um Sergey karakin
or rather Ser Serge karakin played
against Magnus Carlson uh to about move
21 so uh let's check out what happened
here Knight E5 Knight D to B5 going for
the Alaska Sicilian or the sikov
Sicilian or the Pelican Sicilian uh all
depends on how you call it D6 we have
Knight to D5 now going for Knight to C7
check and of course the Knight gets
traded off captur captur now in the
world chair championship match between
Magnus Carlson and Fabiano Coran Magnus
there's a game where he played Knight to
B8 he played Knight to E7 here and they
are following that game Pawn to C4
Knight to G6 and now Queen to A4
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries I'm sure you guys remember
this uh Bishop to D7 and now Queen to B4
we have Bishop to F5 also Queen to B8 is
possible Magnus even played it in one of
the games uh Bishop to F5 and now Queen
back to A4 uh Bishop to D7 sort of um
uh maybe looking for a repetition but
not really they're just playing it out
the exact same way Magnus and Carana did
or Magnus and karakin did we have Pon H4
Pon H5 and now in that game 12 of the
world CH championship match Fabiano
corana played Bishop to E3 against
Magnus but here we have Bishop to G5
following in the footsteps of Sergey
karakin against Magnus Queen to B8 and
now Bishop to E2 we have Pawn to A6
finally Natalia catch is uh her breath
and she has time to kick away the knight
from B5 Knight to C3 and queen to C7
again all very wellknown stuff G3 and
Bishop to E7 now trade trying to trade
off the dark Square Bishops uh Bishop
back to E3 and now Pawn to E4 uh freeing
up that E5 Square for the Knight and
then from here the Knight has access to
D3 to F3 to G4 whatever is needed we
have castles castles and now Bishop
captures on H5 again everything the same
as in the mentioned game uh Knight to E5
and now in that game uh Sergey karakin
played Bishop to E2 which interestingly
is the strongest move recommended by the
engine but here we have Bishop to D4 uh
here we have the first um deviation and
it is now only as of move 22 that we
have a completely new game and this is
where our game begins so let's see what
happened why uh first of all why did
karakin avoid Bishop to D4 against
Magnus Carlson well he avoided due to
Knight to D3 it's a very scary move
which Natalia goes for and now she asks
what what is your next move okay Queen
to B3 the queen is attacked you have to
move it Queen B3 now Bishop captures on
H4 and now you see that you run into a
lot of trouble due to this bishop to D4
move as now the Knight is here the pawn
is here the bishop is here once you
capture the bishop the queen also joins
the attack and it seems either black
will win this by Checkmate or uh White
will have to settle for a perpetual sure
uh but although that is possible it's
very very tricky to achieve this G
captures on H4 uh Queen to E7 and now
Knight to E2 the Knight will be an
important defender of this position
Queen captures on H4 and now Knight to
G3 and not just Knight to F4 putting
pressure on the bishop here uh but also
with some very nasty ideas of Queen H3
followed by Queen to G2 Checkmate so
what can you do here uh well Knight
captures on F5 the uh bishops get traded
off Knight captures on F5 and now Queen
captures on H5 and now the position is
completely winning for stava but you
have to be incredibly precise in order
to do it and that's exactly why I think
this very well could be the greatest
Queen sacrifice of 2023 not because it's
flashy not because there are like three
moves that are winning and um okay she
just chose that one it's because it's
the only move that wins the game so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for stava while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on on this
move that no one would do you know with
an easy heart and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Queen
to G3 we can even do it in slow motion
as you guys deserve it there you go
Queen to G3 uh running right into Knight
the E2 check look at this beautiful Fork
Knight to checks the king the queen and
the bishop here not that it's important
but it is visually appealing uh and um
the reason why Queen to G3 is so strong
I I just have to point this out uh why
it's so nice uh is because okay you
could you could start with something
else you you you don't have to start
with Queen to G3 let's say you start
with Knight to E7 with check can you
start with that King to H7 and now play
Queen to G3 seems like it's the same
idea not really now black has G5 and now
it doesn't work uh how do you how do you
proceed here if Rook E1 you go after the
pawn pawn to F5 yes black is down a
piece but those pawns are incredibly
scary and there there's no good way to
force anything here with white however
if you start with Queen to G3 and
sacrifice your queen now the queen has
to be accepted if you go back I mean
you're just down a piece white can play
pretty much anything and it's completely
winning um after Queen to G3 if you try
the same idea of G5 now it doesn't work
because Rook F to E1 you don't have F5
so yeah you can't really defend this if
Rook 8 to E8 okay you want to defend the
pawn that way now just play night
captures on D6 and I always I mean
remember Black is Black is down material
if black doesn't have Checkmate black is
lost so after Queen to G3 there is but
one move and that is Knight to e to
check I mean that it's always a scary
feeling in chess where uh where your
strongest move is to take your
opponent's Queen but that's exactly what
your opponent wants and it will cost you
the game uh so okay uh Knight to E2 with
check King to G2 and Knight captures on
G3 so what's the idea behind the queen
sacrifice uh the idea is Knight to E7
check forcing the king to the H file and
this is where the Rooks will reign
supreme H so King to H7 and now F
captures on G3 and okay it's Black's
move it seems like you will move the
queen and you're not going to lose the
queen but even if you try let's say
queen T2 check Rook F2 and now you just
move the queen uh Rook h one is mate in
one the Knight controls G8 and G6 and
that's that's Checkmate uh so after F
captures on G3 uh you have to decide do
you want to give up the queen or the
game it's always better to give up the
queen so King to H6 was played uh and
Natalia wants to uh have the G5 Square
ready for her King but now just Rook to
H1 winning back material and that's all
there is Queen captures on H1 was played
we have Rook captures on H1 with check
King to G5 and now Bishop captures on G7
and it seems like okay it's still two
Rooks Against The Rook bishop and Knight
maybe black can still still play this so
Rook F to E8 but now uh the position is
still completely winning for stava but
only if you find one precise move that
wins the game feel free to pause the
video and win the game while I give you
a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on not
blundering the Knight because as you see
the Knight has no squares uh you cannot
save the Knight just like that and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Rook to F1 the only move that
wins the game here this is what she
played and now there is no no choice
other than to resign she played a few
more moves of course now if the Knight
is captured then just Bishop to F6 with
check King will move Bishop captures on
E7 uh leaves stava up a full Bishop so
uh that's not going to happen so after
Rook to F1 E3 was played but now just
Bishop to F6 check uh and now uh it was
I believe in I will check I don't want
to trick you guys let me just check the
correct yeah uh it was in this position
on move 36 that Natalia bua resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here you're getting checkmated whatever
you play for example King to G4 just
Rook to F4 check King H5 and Rook to H4
will be Checkmate so yeah incredible
incredible game and incredible it's not
I mean sometimes okay you sacrifice your
Queen forcefully you take something then
your opponent takes something but here
uh it's it sort of looks like you're
blundering your queen that you've
blundered this nice day to check but in
fact uh you you want it to happen and
the worst thing for your opponent is
that it's actually the strongest move
recommended by the engine it's just not
enough uh so that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it brilliant stuff by stava
sakito uh featured second time on the
channel and both times with uh with
Incredible games so we are definitely
hoping to see more uh and yeah do check
out the max faram versus yush paj game
and vote which one which one takes the
uh the the game of the year award as I
will remove the title from one of these
videos uh so yeah really hope you
enjoyed it U I don't think we've ever
had um such such such a fine offering uh
with a with a fork uh but you know
hoping definitely to see more I would
like to thank Kevin Clark Stephan rovic
Andreas
and no need to put my name in your
thanks box for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day